[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann junior
familie am nürburgring ging es heute um
trauer und wut aber auch um solidarität
und anteilnahme
gedenkfeier für flutopfer beim staatsakt
des landes rheinland-pfalz verspricht
bundespräsident steinmeier irland lässt
sie nicht allein
start für auffrischimpfungen seit heute
bekommen besonders gefährdete in vielen
bundesländern den dritten fix über eine
empfehlung will die impfkommission bald
entscheiden
und viermal gold bei den paralympics in
weitsprung im luftgewehrschießen und im
schwimmen holt das deutsche team erste
plätze
es war ein bewegender staatsakt nur
wenige kilometer entfernt vom ort der
katastrophe am nürburgring sind
angehörige verletzte helfer
bürgermeister und bürgermeisterinnen
zusammengekommen um der opfer der flut
in rheinland pfalz zu gedenken
dieses video zeigt wie vor rund sieben
wochen wassermassen in minuten ganze
ortschaften fluteten allein in
rheinland-pfalz starben
134 menschen
766 wurden verletzt drei sind noch
vermisst
insgesamt seien rund
65.000 rheinland-pfälzer von der
naturkatastrophe betroffen sagte
ministerpräsidentin dreier von der
gedenkfeier berichtet anna duda
sie sollen nicht vergessen werden
staatsaktion gedenken an die opfer der
flutkatastrophe
134 menschen starben in den reißenden
fluten rheinland pfalz heute werden ihre
namen verlesen auch der vater von
wilfried lauf war kam ums leben
in der flut nacht wurde er von ihm
getrennt ich kann nicht sagen was ich
eigentlich gefühlt habe
war es trauer war es wut war es die
unendliche hilflosigkeit nicht bei
meinem vater gewesen zu sein die nicht
habe helfen zu können ich weiß es nicht
drei tage später wurde mein vater 25
kilometer abwärts gefunden sie trauern
heute gemeinsam angehörige von
verstorbenen verletzte hilfskräfte und
bürgermeister innen als wäre das alles
nicht genug hat die a uns noch gleich
unser zuhause genommen
hat zusammen mit den häusern auch gleich
straßen und brücken mitgenommen sie hat
unsere heimat zerstört
tausende haben alles verloren stehen
jetzt vor dem nichts finanzielle
unterstützung sei jetzt wichtig reiche
aber allein nicht aus nannte der
bundespräsident
wir wissen dass in ihrem leben nichts
mehr ist wie es war
aber sie sollen wissen auf ihrem weg
zurück ins leben
lässt sie ihr land nicht allein diese
worte sie versprechen solidarität sie
sind ein zeichen des zusammenhalts
[Musik]
viele verluste sind nie wieder
gutzumachen aber das aufräumen das geht
voran zeigt ein blick nach altena hier
die situation vier tage nach der flut
chaos und zerstörung
fünf wochen später sei es im gleichen
ort dann so aus
trotzdem der wiederaufbau wird jahre
dauern ob und wann die seelischen wunden
heilen ist offen angela app hat war in
bernau
alfred sebastian ist der bürgermeister
von der now alleine in diesem dorf mit
1700 einwohnern sind 15 menschen in den
fluten umgekommen
drei bewohner haben sich nach der
katastrophe das leben genommen das leid
hier ist groß
dass gar nicht so richtig realisieren
weil sie sind noch selber im chaos sind
es selber nicht am trauma in einer
anderen welt 90 prozent der häuser in
dernau sind zerstört viele müssen
abgerissen werden die menschen hier
haben fast alles verloren
notfallseelsorger sind seit der
flutkatastrophe im anteil unterwegs
reden mit den menschen hören zu viele
worte position viele können sie
wahrscheinlich die zukunft gar nicht
vorstellen es gibt leute die haben
obendrüber gewohnt die haben das
schreiben von den menschen gehört hilfe
hilfe ich frag mich wie es den menschen
geht das geht den ihr lebtag nicht aus
dem sinn in die notfallpraxis der
hausärztin kommen jetzt zunehmend
menschen mit psychosomatischen
beschwerden
sie beklagen schlafstörungen sie
beklagen innere unruhe ängste etc
das was alles dinge sind jetzt auch auf
eine posttraumatische belastungsstörung
hindeuten
in dernau sind die menschen ganz eng
zusammengerückt
zusammenstehen sich immer wieder treffen
reden miteinander sich gegenseitig mut
machen und dann hofft man dass eben die
zeit die wunden heilt und
wieder aufbauen wollen sie ihr dorf
trotz alledem denn aufgeben ist für die
därme keine option
jetzt zur corona um die impfquote zu
steigern sollen arbeitgeber mehr
einbezogen werden sie müssen ihre
beschäftigten künftig nicht nur über die
risiken einer infektion und die impfung
informieren sondern ihnen nun auch für
eine impfung freigeben das hat das
bundeskabinett beschlossen
weiter gestritten wird darüber ob die
arbeitgeber ihre leute fragen dürfen ob
sie geimpft sind andreas ruppert hat
mehr eng beieinander arbeiten da wo home
office unmöglich ist eine situation in
der eine corona ansteckung schnell mal
passieren kann klar dass die arbeitgeber
hier gerne wüssten ob ein mitarbeiter
geimpft ist oder nicht dabei geht es uns
im kern auch nicht darum den gesundheits
datenschutz abzuschaffen sondern nur für
die betrieblichen konzepte im rahmen der
pandemischen notlage die notwendigen
informationen für einen optimalen schutz
unserer mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
zu erlangen
auskunftspflicht zum impfstatus heißt
die zauberformel
bislang müssen arbeitnehmer nicht sagen
ob sie geimpft sind
bundesgesundheitsminister will das
ändern gewerkschaften und der
bundesarbeitsminister wollen daran aber
nicht rütteln was es nicht gibt es eine
allgemeine auskunftsanspruch für den
arbeitgeber durch die beschäftigten das
sind sensible gesundheitsdaten aber ich
setze darauf dass wir eine regierung zur
pragmatischen lösungen kommen im bereich
des infektionsschutzgesetzes denn dort
dem infektionsschutzgesetz gibt es jetzt
schon die möglichkeit zur abfrage in §
23a steht in ausnahmefällen darf der
arbeitgeber personenbezogene daten eines
beschäftigten über dessen impfstatus
verarbeiten solche ausnahmen gelten
beispielsweise in pflegeheimen und auf
intensivstationen eine ausweitung auf
alle branchen wird in der
bundesregierung momentan heftig
diskutiert ich kann nur an den
koalitionspartner appellieren dass er
seine bedenken hinten anstellt denn es
geht uns darum
eine weitere ausbreitung von infektionen
zu verhindern und die betrieblichen
abläufe so sicher wie möglich zu machen
einigt sich die regierungskoalition dann
könnte schon nächste woche der bundestag
das infektionsschutzgesetz ändern und
eine generelle auskunftspflicht zum
impfstatus festlegen
die ständige impfkommission will bald
entscheiden ob sie auffrischimpfungen
gegen das corona virus empfehlen wird
die auswertung der vorliegenden daten
sei in vollem gange sagte stiko chef
mertens in einigen bundesländern
bekommen besonders gefährdete menschen
bereits eine zusätzliche impfung zum
beispiel in baden württemberg petra auto
berichtet
seit heute morgen gibt es hier im
impfzentrum des stuttgarter robert bosch
krankenhauses den booster eine
auffrischimpfung für menschen über 80
und andere risikogruppen sowie stefan
strohm
es lässt nach aber wann und bei wem und
wie stark die wissenschaft ist noch
nicht soweit die tritt impfung klar zu
empfehlen
zu nehmen während die stiko noch daten
auswertet ist sich die politik dagegen
schon sicher sagt klar nachimpfen lassen
zudem deuten sehr sehr deutlich darauf
hin dass die booster impfung effektiv
sind und die wunder haben und gruppen
daneben noch besser schützen und
deswegen haben haben sich die
bundesgesundheitsminister
konferenz eben dazu entschieden
am ersten runden loszulegen bayern und
sachsen anhalt sind schon vorgeprescht
die anderen legen jetzt bemühen nach
doch wer soll das stemmen wenn bald die
impfzentren schließen für die hausärzte
allein ein riesenaufwand das zu
organisieren erfordert sehr viel
manpower wir müssen im vornherein
telefonieren telefonieren telefonieren
ist dass wir also hier keine normale
praxis machen können in der praxis da
zeigt sich einmal mehr wie schwierig
doch die vorgaben der politik umzusetzen
sind
um die korona lage besser einzuschätzen
will die bundesregierung künftig einen
neuen wert heran ziehen die sogenannte
hospitalisierung since it ends sie gibt
an wie viele neue corona patienten in
der letzten woche stationär im
krankenhaus behandelt wurden bezogen auf
100.000 einwohner
heute liegt sie bei 1,81 das ist
allerdings nur eine tendenz die genaue
zahl steht erst mit mehreren tagen
verzug fest der bislang höchste wert war
an weihnachten mit 15 79 außerdem meldet
das robert-koch-institut
13.500 31 neue corona fälle innerhalb
von 24 stunden die sieben tage inzidenz
liegt jetzt bei
75,7
in der nacht soll es losgehen dann will
die gewerkschaft der lokführer wieder
massiv den personenverkehr bestreiken
bis dienstag nächster woche um das noch
abzuwenden hat die bahn jetzt ein neues
angebot vorgelegt sie bietet eine corona
prämie bis zu 600 euro und eine laufzeit
des tarifvertrags von 36 monaten eine
reaktion der gdl gibt es noch nicht seit
17 uhr bestreikt die gewerkschaft
bereits den güterverkehr die wirtschaft
warnt vor
produktionsausfällen erneut wurden
lieferketten unterbrochen weil
transporte umgeplant werden müssten
fallen zusätzliche kosten an heißt es
aus der chemiebranche
unmittelbar nach dem abzug aus
afghanistan hat us-präsident beiden
konsequenzen angekündigt in einer rede
an die nation sagte er man müsse aus
fehlern lernen es gehe nun darum eine
ära großer militäroperationen zur
umgestaltung andere länder zu beenden
wegen der chaotischen umstände der
evakuierung steht beiden innenpolitisch
massiv in der kritik hatte es im haus
washington
man merkte ihm den ärger über die
heftige kritik an seinem
krisenmanagement joe biden übernimmt
verantwortung aber er bereut nichts
ich wollte diesen ewigen krieg nicht
verlängern und auch keinen ewigen abzug
nach diesem abzug konzentriert sich die
us-regierung auf neue bedrohungen die
sieht das weiße haus vor allem in china
und russland deshalb definiert beiden
die nationalen interessen der usa viel
enger als bisher
wir müssen bei unseren missionen
erreichbare ziele setzen nicht ziele die
man nicht erreichen kann
es geht nicht nur um afghanistan es geht
darum die ära jener militäroperationen
zu beenden mit denen andere länder neu
erschaffen werden sollten
es ist ein strategiewechsel ein
amerikaner joe biden er muss sein
eigenes land stabilisieren die
demokratie hier sichern und stark machen
für künftige auseinandersetzungen mit
dem autoritarismus die opposition glaubt
dass beides abzugs chaos amerikas
ansehen in der welt schwer geschadet hat
ich sehe es als das größte militärische
versagen der usa in meiner lebenszeit
einen fehler den wir nie wieder machen
dürfen
die us regierung verspricht den menschen
die afghanistan verlassen wollen weiter
hilfe vor allem einigen hundert
verbliebenen amerikanern afghanischen
kräften und staatsbürgern anderer länder
die taliban haben zusagen gemacht wir
nehmen sie nicht nur beim wort sondern
erwarten taten und wir haben druckmittel
um das sicherzustellen
und auch amerikas kampf gegen den
terrorismus gehe weiter versprach biden
trotz der außenpolitischen wände der
vereinigten staaten
trotz allem also muss der westen auch
deutschland mit den taliban verhandeln
schließlich will die bundesregierung
noch etwa 40.000 menschen helfen
afghanistan zu verlassen dazu braucht
sie nicht nur die zustimmung der taliban
sondern auch die der nachbarländer
mit einigen von ihnen hat außenminister
maß in den vergangenen vier tagen
gesprochen seine reise endete in katar
dessen regierung könnte eine
vermittlerrolle einnehmen die taliban
haben in dem emirat eine politische
vertretung
andreas künast hat die reise begleitet
ist seit zwei stunden zurück in berlin
mit welchem fazit andreas
es geht nach dieser reise nicht mehr
darum ob man sich mit den taliban ein
lässt sondern jetzt ist die frage wie
tief um diesen 40.000 menschen zu helfen
überlegt das auswärtige amt sogar in
kabul wieder eine art vertretung zu
öffnen vielleicht gemeinsam als eu um
noch engeren kontakt mit den taliban zu
halten allerdings ohne diese offiziell
anzuerkennen
es gilt als ein kleines zeichen der
hoffnung dass es gestern den 100
mitarbeitern von adenauer und ebert
stiftung gelungen ist aus kabul nach
pakistan zu kommen in einem kleinen
selbstorganisierten konvoi an mehreren
checkpoints der taliban vorbei und auch
deshalb glaubt die delegation die in
doha für deutschland mit den taliban
verhandelt dass ihre gesprächspartner
jetzt doch so halbwegs verlässlich sind
und es liegt im interesse von
zehntausenden menschen dass sie sich
nicht ernst
was ganz anderes jetzt filme waren immer
da während der pandemie doch das
drumherum das kino der glamour die roten
teppiche das kehrt jetzt zurück in
venedig mit entsprechend gut gelaunten
stars bei den 78 filmfestspielen in den
nächsten tagen gehen 21 filme ins rennen
um den goldenen löwen gewonnen hat schon
jetzt das publikum annette hilsenbeck
endlich wieder hollywood-glamour beim
ältesten filmfestival der welt penélope
cruz mit erfolgs regisseur pedro
almodóvar auf dem roten teppich ihr film
matrix paralleles über zwei mütter die
gleichzeitig schwanger werden eröffnet
die filmfestspiele
bei ihrer ankunft am mittag keine
ausnahme für stars temperatur messen der
guten laune tut das keinen abbruch
wir feiern hier das kino das ja auch
viele menschen auf der welt arbeit
bietet ich bin daher aus vielen gründen
glücklich hier zu sein
auch dieses jahr gelten zwar corona
beschränkungen darf nur rein wer geimpft
genesen oder getestetes dürfen fans
nicht am roten teppich stehen trotzdem
in venedig herrscht aufbruchstimmung
viele hollywood stars haben sich
angekündigt und die liste der
wettbewerbsfilme gilt als
vielversprechend rom müsse es ist als ob
irgendwie die schwierigen bedingungen
unter denen die filme gemacht gedreht
wurden als anregung für die kreativität
der filmemacher dienten und viele der
filme die wir in diesem jahr hier sehen
werden gehören zu den besten ihrer
macher
auch die jury hochkarätig besetzt
oscar-preisträger und regisseur bong
joon-ho ist präsident auch chloe saarow
die letztes jahr gleich goldenen löwen
und oskar abräumte es mit von der partie
der italienische schauspieler und
komiker roberto benigni erhält heute
abend schon den goldenen löwen für seine
karriere der auftakt eines film
festivals das wohl dieses jahr viel
glamour und starke filme bietet
und jetzt nur so ne ganz stark heute
auch das deutsche team bei den
paralympics goldene mittwoch allerdings
gleich vier siege fangen wir mit dem
spektakulärsten an überflieger markus
leben feiert seine vierte goldmedaille
bei den paralympics im weitsprung ließ
er der konkurrenz nicht den hauch einer
chance und gewann mit 74 zentimetern
vorsprung
die bedingungen für rehm allerdings
nicht ideal
aber
klar die weite den ich gerne wissen
korrigiert das für ihre minimale ziel
gold mit 818 erreicht blieb aber damit
unter der angestrebten weite des
olympiasiegers tinto clou von 841
schmälert aber nicht seine
internationale vormachtstellung
und da gab es noch zwei mal gold binnen
sechs minuten im schwimmbecken talisa
engel bei den männern und elena
kraftstoff bei den frauen gewannen beide
ihre finale über 100 meter brust
gold in weltrekordzeit führte ließ so
engel der 19 jährige ist über die 100
meter brust zurzeit das maß aller dinge
der weltmeister europameister seit heute
paralympics-sieger und weltrekordhalter
schon im vorlauf knackt der
sehbehinderte schwimmer die acht jahre
alte bestmarke und verbessert sie im
finale noch einmal um 56 hundertstel
dann ließ so engel heute unschlagbar
dann der nächste gold co nur kurze zeit
später wird auch elena kraft soft
paralympics-siegerin auf halber strecke
noch 1,08 sekunden hinter ihrer
konkurrenten kämpft sich die
sehbehinderte berlinerin mit einem ganz
starken finish zu gold und
die vierte deutsche gold medaille des
tages holte sportschützin natascha
hiltrop in einem dramatischen finale mit
dem luftgewehr über zehn meter rettete
sie vor dem südkoreaner park in hof mit
dem letzten schuss einen vorsprung von
0,1 bringen ins ziel
und einen tag nach gold im zeitfahren
hat annika zeyen die nächste medaille
geholt silber im straßenrennen ja und
bronze gab es heute auch noch für
deutschland durch das tischtennis duo
johan schnake und thomas rau im
teamwettbewerb halbfinale gegen china
verloren übrigens die vierte deutsche
tischtennis medaille in tokio
und das waren jetzt sechs medaillen in
zwei minuten das auch tatsächlich tut
dennoch wie jeden mittwoch die
lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten 35
16 39 48 49 und die superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
das wetter in den nächsten tagen bringt
abgesehen von ein bisschen nebel viel
sonne und wärme die details hat gleich
katja honnefer marietta slomka begrüßt
sie im heute journal um 14 und wir
freuen uns wenn sie mal wieder dabei
sind alles gute ihnen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genannt dass ein hoch im spätsommer
nicht unbedingt strahlender sonnenschein
bedeutet konnten wir heute mal wieder
erleben da gab es nämlich diese
hochnebeldecke und die wurde nur ganz
langsam
angeknabbert es reichte sogar in
leinefelde und lüdenscheid heute morgen
für ein paar spritzer regen und auch in
süddeutschland gab es einige dunst und
nebelfelder die sich aber rasch auflösen
und so ist es in der nacht doch meist
klar selten gibt es dichte
hochnebelfelder und an gewässern da
bildet sich auch mal etwas nebel oder
duzt denn es wird kalt im binnenland
sinken die temperaturen auf 11 bis 5
grad und nur an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee bleibt es bei 12 bis 14 grad
milder es ist schon überraschend dass es
am alpenrand trotz der fünf grad in der
nacht tagsüber noch mal für 21 grad
reicht am mittel- und am oberrhein
werden es 24 bis 26 sonst 20 bis 23 grad
und nur ganz im nordwesten bleibt es bei
18 grad kühler denn dort hält sich
morgen eine hochnebeldecke so ungefähr
zwischen aurich hamburg und osnabrück
sonst aber scheint häufig die sonne
besonders südlich der nördlichen
mittelgebirge scheint sie nach nebel und
dunst am morgen oft strahlend und in den
nächsten tagen geht es mit diesem
schönen spätsommer wetter weiter und
dabei fängt heute der meteorologische
herbstanfang guten abend